- The Office had a huge comeback
like the last several years
I think 'cause streaming like everybody,
like all those shows
that maybe were popular
years ago are coming back around.
Is that cool to like have
whole new fan base for it?
- It's totally insane
- Yeah.
- and mind blowing, honestly.
- Like there are kids
who weren't even born
when the show started,
I know.
- who are now
like avid fans and it's
- 'Cause it's a great show.
- a thrill.
Yeah, it's it's totally, totally amazing.
Randall was on The Office.
- I know!
- I did an episode
and it's crazy because I did one.
- Is that when you met?
- No, I'm just kidding.
That's what I thought,
but apparently it wasn't,
but I did one scene in one episode.
I was in and out in like a couple hours
- Yeah.
- and that one scene
is probably the thing
I'm recognized most for.
(people laughing)
- You know what?
- To this day.
- That's how powerful you are so.
- It makes our show, true
story an Office reunion.
- That's right, that's right.
- It does.
- Right.
- So in The Office,
you did a lot of acapella
and like I mentioned on
The Voice you came back
and you were on The Voice
and I know you kicked
John out of your group,
but Blake is now a member
of your acapella group.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yes.
- Yeah and Ariana,
the whole gang.
- Yes.
- Everybody's in the group.
- Just not John
- Except for John.
(people laughing)
Yeah, John and I have a,
are we've been rivals for decades decades.
- Decades.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, since Beyonce's party.
- It makes sense.
- Since Beyonce's party.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, I've done.
- Since we had an acapella off
at Beyonce's party.
- Right, yeah.
- Oh that's right,
of course.
- That's right, remember.
- Did you grow up though
really like singing acapella
like in groups?
- Not acapella per se,
- Okay.
- but I was like
kind of like a chorale nerd.
- I was too.
- Yeah, okay.
- Yeah.
- So like singing all the time.
My buddy Warren Goodrich and I sang
More Than Words
- Oh
- at a high school pep rally,
which doesn't even sound cool.
I think we thought it was cool to do that,
but it's.
- I would still
think it's cool, which
is why I was the nerd
- And I'm still proud of it,
but I think that
technically it was not cool.
- Yeah.
- And that's what part,
that's part of what makes me not cool
is that I don't agree with that.
I still think it's cool.
- I still think it's cool.